[Musik]
hallo blome alter sind willkommen letzte
woche habe ich da gesessen alter
gefährte 60 hier ja und das heißt die
maßnahmen sind schon genug hat der block
hat vorsichtig kann ich da nur sagen die
bundeskanzlerin wenn die jetzt hier wäre
der würde das nicht gefallen die möchte
von lockerungen nicht einmal sprechen
wir haben ganz oben hat sie ich meine
angela merkel gedächtnis handschuhe rosa
an sie sehen quasi mich gegen weitere
infektionen zu schützen denn sie sind
echt studium voll infiziert das machen
wir gleich das können sie ja gleich
machen aber sie sehen jetzt aus wie
grobi aus der sesamstraße
wir haben ein thema das ist gar nicht so
lustig neben ethischen implikationen
dieser krise zu ihnen kommen wir
vielleicht auch gleich noch mal war dass
wir unser thema ist aber vorweg möchte
ich ihnen einleiten eine frage stellen
als bürger und als journalist fühlen sie
sich eigentlich von der bundesregierung
vielleicht sogar von der bundeskanzlerin
persönlich gut regiert und gut
informiert also wenn sie die frage ernst
meinen wert lasse ich mich nicht von der
bundesregierung informieren sondern ich
lasse mich von journalisten und medien
informieren
die natürlich das unter anderem
aufnehmen was die bundesregierung da so
von sich gibt und dass man die
kommunikation ist hoffe ich bereit
flächig insofern jahr fühle ich mich
ordentlich informiert und ehrlich gesagt
fühle ich mich auch nicht besonders
schlecht regiert wenngleich den punkt
hatten wir letztes mal ist natürlich
absurd dass jemand die bundeskanzlerin
und manch anderer herr söder glaube ich
auch aus bayern unterdrücken möchte
beziehungsweise nicht es haben möchte
dass man jetzt schon über die frage
spricht wie man den 14 tagen 21 tagen
keine ahnung wann ein bisschen selber
hier aus der ganzen nummer auch wieder
raus diese diskussion ist natürlich
jetzt noch frage stellen einfach eine
verständnis frage weil ich bin hat
manchmal intelligenz probleme gerade
wenn es um komplexe sachverhalte geht
also ich die bundeskanzler seien nur
eine lungenkrankheit oder immer bestehen
sie nur aus gehirn ein machen sie jetzt
den witz bitte nicht also mein problem
ist folgendes unsere geliebte
bundeskanzlerin hat gesagt man könne
sonne nicht über dieses lockerungs thema
dieser strenge maßnahmen nachdenken bis
nicht die
verdoppelung der fälle alle zehn tage
oder zwölf tage erstmals zehn tage jetzt
habe ich zwölf tage ist egal passiert
und nicht so wie jetzt alle sechs tage
also die zahl der registrierten fälle
ich bin ja kein virologe und auch kein
bundeskanzleramt aber ich würde doch
sagen die zahl der registrierten fälle
hängt ja sehr sehr stark damit ab wie
viele fälle sie registrieren jetzt haben
wir aber man kann das auch so und so
viel getestet jetzt verstärken wir die
tester tätigkeit und ich würde jetzt mal
als laie sagen je mehr sie testen desto
mehr fälle registrieren sie dann auch ja
das heißt also sie machen einen ganz
kurzen durch ein ganz kurz an sich würde
ich würde sagen wenn zusammenbinden ich
möchte aber auch dass die zuseherinnen
und zuseher das verstehen das heißt die
entscheidung darüber ob die schlimmsten
und strengsten einschränkungen die es
überhaupt jemals gegeben hat in diesem
land gelockert werden ja dann nein wird
auf grundlage von zahlenmaterial gefällt
was total gaga ist oder ob ich zu ihnen
einen gefallen uns beiden war natürlich
in einen gefallen und nennen sie nicht
ein kronleuchter ich nenne sie auch
nicht wieder als 1 mm also durch die
linke kommt ist sie doch einfach mal
eine frage ja sie mit ihren lächerlichen
was antworten sie einfach die frage an
sie machen es sich doch viel zu einfach
wird natürlich nicht irgendeine
entscheidung wie viel ist uns das leben
wert wie viel uns ist und das
wirtschaftliche leben wird weil das
menschliche leben anhand einer einzigen
zahl entschieden die dann wie so eine
wie die deutsche schuldenuhr irgendwas
inter-stars kanzlerin gesagt nein das
macht unsere das war die letzte
bundestagswahl von mehreren parametern
glaub ich nicht mehr gestellt als sie
sind das wird natürlich sind wir haben
zehn erreicht sagt wir können alles
wieder aufhören ist doch quatsch da
kommen 1000 andere fragen noch dazu so
am zweitens könnte man natürlich
hingehen und jetzt ihre kleine
mathematische frage oder problem
aufzulösen und zu sagen wir schauen uns
einfach so viele tests an von den neuen
tests die wir jetzt machen wie wir
vorher auch gemacht haben damit wir eine
vergleichbarkeit herstellen und schauen
uns an wie viel in der gruppe der test
meinetwegen 50.000 pro woche oder
500.000 pro woche die wir die ganze zeit
schon hingekriegt haben wir inzwischen
der infektionen haben dann hätte man
auch so eine zahl an so nicht weiß ich
dass man schaden sollte sind die toten
können wir zum thema kommen und wann
wird man auf die totenzahlen schauen
wollen wir mal gucken das hat trump
wenn man echt selten als quelle ich
bleibe eines anderen isst du dich über
trump rating einig platte entschuldigung
ich muss deshalb jetzt ein ein
eingreifen weil die bundeskanzlerin ganz
eindeutig gesagt hat und die mit den 16
ministerpräsidenten das über die
verlängerung dieser maßnahmen erst nach
ostern entschieden wird voß und gehen
bis nach außen vor ist dann wird
entschieden ob sie danach und das ist
erst dann in frage kommt wenn diese
verdopplung eine entsprechende
verlangsamung hat das können sie aber
erst feststellen wenn sie wissen würden
wie jetzt die situation ist das wissen
sie aber gar nicht weil über die
dunkelziffer niemand irgendetwas weiß
wenn sie ein bisschen presse gelesen
hätten sie waren doch mal journalist
dann kann ich nur sagen lesen sie doch
mal
es häufen sich jetzt die zitate die
interviews mit medizin statistiker mit
virologen die sagen wir wissen über die
zahlen gerade mal gar nichts sie wissen
nicht mal über die zahlen sehr wissen
meistens weil sie nicht wissen ob die
leute an cholera gestorben oder hätten
also wir wissen ob die leute mit einer
infektion gestorben sind oder ob sie
nicht gestorben sind
wir wissen nicht ob die leute noch drei
jahre gelebt hätten oder nur drei tage
wenn sie diese infektion nicht bekommen
hatten und mit einer schweren
herzerkrankung hochbetagt im altenheim
liegen das stimmt schon aber diese
menschen sind mit corona gestorben und
sie sind an einem bestimmten tag
gestorben
der ziemlich nah an der aus wie soll man
sagen an dieser infektion sind jetzt
können sie sagen ich sei ja nur die sind
gestorben weil sie geboren worden sind
die werden natürlich niemals gestorben
wenn sie nicht auch gewusst sie weisen
sie den altschulden auf den hut manchmal
sieht man sie in seinem und noch einmal
zurück zu den zahlen natürlich können
sie gucken wie sich unter meinetwegen
wie sich die zahl wie sich bei einem
test heute unter 50.000 getesteten die
zahl der infektion entwickelt hat im
vergleich zu 50.000 getesteten von vor
drei wochen da sehen sie ja ob da eine
bewegung drin ist ob das abflacht oder
nicht und noch einmal ich glaube glauben
sie wirklich dass desto niedriger ist
wenn wir bei 10 angeschlagen sind dann
hören diese komischen sachen auf wie
also sind das sagen und die beschränkung
auf wie ein albtraum das was ich genial
und ich habe ja nur dieses für die
bundeskanzlerin zitiert was sollte ich
denn machen dass das interessante was
ich ganz bemerkenswert finden an dieser
ganzen situation ist keiner von uns hier
ist irgendwie virologe epidemiologe
medizin statistiker gar nicht sondern
wir nehmen diese informationen und
müssen ja irgendwas damit machen und
diese informationen sind in hohem maße
inkonsistent jetzt kann man ja sagen
das geht auch gar nicht anders sie sind
nicht inkonsistent sie nähern sich dem
phänomen und natürlich gibt es überall
wie bei jedem phänomen eine große
dunkelziffer dies in der tat dieses mal
interessanter also bei anderen fragen
und phänomen
da gebe ich ihnen ja recht jetzt gibt
aber und jetzt komme ich doch noch mal
auch die zahl der toten
wie gesagt donald mit einer halben
vorbehalt der sagte anfangs das ist eine
grippe an der grippe sterben
normalerweise 35.000 menschen in amerika
pro grippesaison bestimmt ungefähr
und jetzt spricht er von 240.000 toten
ich finde dann ist das ding was wir da
haben cupid 19 krone oder wie man es
jetzt immer nennen soll schon ein
bisschen mehr als eine grippe wenn wir
uns darauf wenigstens einigen könnten ja
denn das ist doch ihr ganzes argument
dass kein hemmnis normal ich kann das ja
noch der anormale warum machen wir nur
normale schutzmaßnahmen in einer
normalen rezession ist so interessant
sie missverstehen ich glaube sie wollen
nicht auch missverstehen ich kann das
nicht beurteilen weil ich von medizin
einfach nichts verstehe ich kam aber
gesundheit kann beurteilen aber mein job
wir nichts machen mein job als
journalist ist doch die informationen
die reinkommen ja zu oft konsistenz zu
prüfen und darauf aufmerksam zu machen
wenn da sozusagen logische löcher sind
und ich sehe was das zahlenmaterial
angeht riesige logische löcher und ich
finde dass dies ein material ist aber
die begründung für diese ganzen
maßnahmen und jetzt lassen sie uns mal
einen schritt weiter gehen
zu unserem thema ich hatte das vergnügen
gestern ein kleines gespräch zu führen
anwesend zu sein als es geführt wurde
mit einem virologen und sozialmediziner
sozialmediziner sind die leute die die
medizinischen auswirkungen von sozialen
gesellschaftlichen entwicklungen auf
große gesellschaftsgruppen untersuchen
war deshalb gut dass dieser mann dabei
war bei dem gespräch habe dieses
gespräch geführt und er hat gesagt dass
in sehr sehr kurzer zeit die maßnahmen
schlimmere folgen haben zwar nicht für
die wirtschaft für die angebliche so
düstere wirtschaft sondern für menschen
für die gesundheitlichen folgen dieser
maßnahmen leicht menschen die maßnahmen
den dieser die die folgen der maßnahmen
die gesundheitlichen maßnahmen werden
schlimmer sein als die dieser krise und
zwar in sehr kurzer zeit
das halte ich für theoretisch denkbar es
ist nur eine außerordentlich
theoretische betrachtung natürlich
können sie wenn sie millionen menschen
in deutschland oder weltweit auf jahre
hinaus arbeitslos machen dann werden sie
in bestimmten regionen der welt
verhungern
und in deutschland werden sie nicht
verhungern aber wahrscheinlich kann
armut auch krankheit produkte wurde hass
so geht man davon ausgenommen
also entsteht da quasi folgeschäden lisa
maß an bin ich völlig dabei nun was
bedeutet ihnen das
das war jetzt abwägen muss auch shell
und ihre abwägung besteht darin oder
gibt es folgeschäden dann machen wir gar
nicht kennen und doch können sich jetzt
die handschuhe aus dem das thema ist
jetzt ernst mit den handschuhen die
ernst nehmen weil das ist total
lächerlich und das ist glaube ich auch
für die zuschauer dann wenn nicht aber
sind sich jetzt mal die handschuhe jetzt
spaß nämlich vor bei den schwaben ist
dabei auch stellenweise quatsch training
schon ein
das ist im moment mein punkt war sie
müssen es abwägen und ihre ganze
abwägung besteht daran man kann sich
nicht ganz genau sicher sein ob das
nicht schlimm die folgen produziert und
darum machen wir besser gar nichts oder
schon zum beispiel nicht das was wir
gerade das zynisch dann hatte ich nicht
gesagt weil das gegenüber gar nicht zu
nein ich habe nicht gesagt dass man gar
nichts machen soll dass es unsinn ist
gar nicht meine meinung ich glaube bloß
dass die maßnahmen die wir jetzt haben
so dramatisch einschneidend sind dass
ich nicht mehr glaube inzwischen so weit
gehe ich jetzt tatsächlich sage ich
jetzt spricht dass ich glaube nicht dass
die maßnahmen in dieser drastischen um
fassung so notwendig gewesen wären ich
kann mir vorstellen dass mit weit
weniger einschneidenden maßnahmen man
ähnliche ergebnisse hätte alles hier im
golf ein und nahm mir leid das ist jetzt
wirklich in richtung hallo
entschuldigung oder corona leugnungen
wenn es ihn straftatbestand aber den
gibt es natürlich nur in ungarn schon
gäbe weil sie contra faktisch
argumentieren sie können gar nicht
wissen was passiert wäre wenn man nichts
getan hätte
insofern können sie auch nicht
schlussfolgern dass ist besser gewesen
wäre nichts zu tun im moment dass die
länder das gelände hier nicht den
totalen lockdown haben
auf die hat auch dieser kollege gestern
gewesen bei dem gespräch teilnehmen
durfte die haben auch sehr schweden
holland kanada und die niederlande haben
achtung wie viel mal mehr tote als
deutschland fünf mal so viel tote und da
gibt es keine griffe und das ist jetzt
genau das und deshalb will das mal ganz
genau aber es kann sein fleisch schweden
wird das für ein echt interessanter fall
sein weil die sich wirklich
unterscheiden in den maßnahmen und jetzt
in sehr steilen verlauf in der infektion
nehmen meinetwegen können sie jetzt
einbinden die testen hier auch viel
optimiert aston als deutschland
das wird man sehen wird hinterher ist in
der tat betrachten können möglicherweise
unterschieden zwischen 1 1 sehr
disziplinierten land wie schweden und
anderen nicht so disziplinierten ländern
die andere maßnahmen gemacht hat und
diszipliniert wir werden noch alle aller
allenthalben jetzt gelöst und die
deutschen diesen ferien der
argumentation ist folgender gedanke im
ernst jetzt
sie betrachten das wie jede andere
geschichte wo quasi menschenleben
verloren gehen
im visum sei im normalen ablauf des
lebens also auf der autobahn im
arbeitsleben und sowas dann immer so
wenn man guckt wie viel mensch auf der
autobahn sterben und wie viele menschen
an dieser grippe sterben werde
einen kuchen kronast haben werden könnte
man auch sagen man gegen die autobahn
für die unternehmen aber vergleichsweise
wenig moment aber sie müssen es
betrachten wie eine naturkatastrophe
sie müssen es betrachten wie ein
meteoriteneinschlag gegen den sie
natürlich alles was sie haben
mobilisieren
auf einmal kurzzeitig für kurze frist
und dann sind sie im richtigen bild und
darum machen diese maßnahmen und im
einzelfall können uns über alles
unterhalten von mas konfliktes ich weiß
nicht was aber darum macht den kern der
stadt der radikale staatliche eingriff
erst einmal sinn weil es eine
naturkatastrophe ist sie missverstehen
nicht ich glaube ja nicht dass man
nichts machen muss ich glaube nur dass
man hier das kind mit dem bade
ausschüttet und sozusagen millionen
haben wir noch ein dass sie millionen
von menschen werden sozusagen in ihrem
leben beschnitten werden da wird da
gehen jetzt gerade sozusagen
schullaufbahn in dem bach runter die
ganzen kinder die nicht zur schule
dürfen dagegen betriebe pleite da haben
leute angst und ich muss ihnen das jetzt
gar nicht alles aufzählen weil sozusagen
das in die gesamte gesellschaft und
jedes leben lang geht und was mich echt
was mich echt da werde ich tatsächlich
gibt das zu dann werde ich auch da kommt
meine panik ich habe gar nicht mehr
panik vor dieser krankheit ich habe
panik sozusagen davor dass wir politiker
haben die mir gar nicht mehr erklären
können wie sie da wieder rauskommen und
wenn die bundeskanzlerin ganz kurz wenn
die bundeskanzlerin sagt sie macht das
fest an bestimmten statistischen radios
der in der registrierten
infektionszahlen wobei aber jeder weiß
dass die dunkelziffer vielleicht fünfmal
so groß ist zehn mal so sagen punkt
hatten sie schon dann beunruhigt mich
das schwer aber man sieht an anderen
ländern östlich also china in asien
südkorea bereits wie man dann langsam
wieder rauskommt und ich glaube dass es
hier genauso stattfinden wird land für
land für ganze sie unterschiede waren
unsere zeit wohl auch darum habe ich
jetzt gar nicht so eine große lange
außer das ist zu lange geben dann kommt
der punkt und dass wir uns ja einig der
punkt wo man sagen muss jetzt ist die
kur schlimmer als die krise es gibt
einen grund warum diese krise möglichst
schnell enden sollte die friseure haben
alle zu sehen dass bei mir sie sehen es
bei ihm das ist vielleicht auch ein
echtes argument für die bundeskanzlerin
und das fanden
[Musik]